[Music]
they came to express their anger about
the negotiations between argentina and
the international monetary fund
thousands of people in front of the
presidential palace demanded the
government to prioritize the people
instead of the imf
jorge altamira has been a lawmaker for
years
the government is renegotiating the
agreement and they know they won't be
able to pay it and in two years we will
have the same problem we cannot pay back
that amount of money without strangling
the poorest
in 2018 the imf granted the government
of mauricio macri the biggest loan in
its history over 50 billion dollars
argentina says it needs to recover from
the pandemic and wants to pay back once
the economy starts growing again
argentina is seeking its 22nd agreement
with the international monetary fund to
stabilize the economy struggling with
high inflation rates and high
poverty the government is hoping to
announce a staff level agreement in the
next month before sending it to congress
people here are extremely concerned
about the impact that the agreement will
have in their lives
romina wancini says she's not concerned
about the imf but about argentina's
economy
inflation is expected to surpass 50
percent this year
inflation is affecting us all commercial
businesses because of the prices today
you have one price the next day another
the dollar increases and it has an
impact in inputs in transport so we are
scared and it paralyzes us we just want
the uncertainty to end
economies say an agreement with the imf
is crucial to prevent argentina from
being isolated from international
financial markets
argentina has no option it's either
agree with the imf or default
to default is to relive the crisis of
2001 and nobody wants to be in that
situation again
and that's why an alternative is better
than a default we see an agreement as a
positive step if it helps argentina
increase its central bank reserves and
stabilize the economy
but these people are not convinced they
say the imf measures have hurt them in
the past and they fear it could happen
again
buenos aires